i think we can all agree that i'm
ordering you
to let this slide because nothing
happened this is officially
out of your hands would you actually
mind just checking out my report
it's pretty thorough and i spent over an
hour on fonts
kind of snazzy so oh thank you i'll get
right to it
thanks trevor let's go have a good one
well we don't have to worry abdulsky's
son anymore
case is officially out of my hands no
charges filed why is there yogurt on
this
the deputy commissioner threw my report
in terry's trash can
and he'd been eating yogurt earlier
terry loves yogurt
aunt aunt aunt
ant ah they're everywhere are we sure
that we've cleaned up all the food and
crumbs
why is everyone looking at us we're the
ones who eat up for the crumbs yeah
we're the solution
well there are no ants on my desk
because i sanitize it daily
what do you call that those are your
ants they're using a monitor cable as a
land bridge
[Music]
now they're destroying our technology
this is an invasion
they're in my yogurt now it's person
damn it boyle you left the fridge open
the door couldn't shut because of your
empty pizza box
pizza please this is a butternut squash
and truffle butter flatbread
everything's spoiled my lunch is ruined
my chicken
my potatoes my pasta meatballs
pam my yogurt a lot of yogurt i love
yogurt
so this is your lunch for like the month
i need to eat 10
000 calories a day to maintain muscle
mass my wife made me all of this before
she left town with the kids that was
everything in my fridge
i get greek yogurt because there's
heritage there but iceland
no no no no no no no hey
gina what are you guys talking about
yogurt me too let's keep talking about
that
whoa terry's out of breath nope oh
god i hate how hard it is to guess other
people's passwords
wait everyone wait try yogurt
[Applause]
terry loves yogurt
what's that smell that's lavender
terry loves lavender a little homemade
honey yogurt infused with lavender
and love
that is delicious hold it
this isn't some weird breast milk or
something is it boy i mean technically
it's from a sheep's breast
hey terry got any new baby pigs you hate
looking at pictures of my twins
you said since they were identical i
didn't need to take photos of both that
doesn't sound like auntie gina
i love your baby pics and your stories
about the twins sleep schedules
okay i know what you two are doing this
is your weird way of trying to make me
stay at the nine-nine
well i am loving it
sir my life stinks sharon's on bed rest
my favorite mango yogurt got
discontinued
and my kids think that preschool teaches
a stupid face
everyone i work with is a stupid face
especially bryce sure sorry
sir can i be honest
precinct's not the same without you the
vulture's the worst
my mango yogurt yes you already
mentioned the yogurt cause it's
important
move over peralta move over
and if i made you a third toast
it'll be focused primarily on the mango
yolk
don't move me i lost something important
too sure
hey diaz right the walls
can i help you i need the crime stats
from last month fine
one sec
some people huh hey i'm up to 20 000
steps
seriously boyle oh you don't care about
my health you don't care if nikolaj
grows up without a papa
you want me to die honestly a little
hurts i can't believe they all let cj
and gina just buy them off
but we don't need them cause we've got
you and you're a sergeant did you sign
the letter yet
um i uh what did he give you he gave me
the ability to continue to serve this
community unencumbered by
unnecessary oversight now i really have
what did he give you he gave me a yogurt
fridge all right
i asked for a yoga fridge and i got one
right next to my desk
i'm only a man i'm sending this letter
with or without your signature
enjoy your blood yogurt i don't know
what's going on sarge you find that leak
yet yes i'm hiding behind a coffee maker
spying on everyone in this office
because i found a leak
oh terry sarcasm is not a good look on
you but you know what would be
a really tight henley very helpful i
know who your leak is
what i looked up the reporter who
published the crime numbers and i
noticed you two follow each other online
oh he followed me and you know i'm a
proud member of team follow back
so i went through your feed to see what
you were posting a lot of pictures of
your kids nobody cares
and then i found this picture you posted
last week
living that hashtag yogurt life
embarrassing but what's even more
embarrassing terry
is that the arrest numbers are in the
photo clear as day
oh my god i was sleek
hey there bud we've been going for a
while you feeling hungry
starving thanks oh come on
you get a yogurt when i get the truth oh
god it's in the grout it's gonna smell
in here forever
so i heard from one police plaza they
received my letter
and apparently they also received
hundreds of others in support of cj
yeah emily and i sent those in so emily
what was that burn i had you write down
for amy
because i didn't want to forget it why
so sad did you just find out american
girl doesn't make clothes in adult sizes
no steven seagal called and he wants his
ponytail back
gina colin hey amy what did one graphing
calculator say to the other one amy cole
and what gina colon
why does this said lady
hey amy you know what congratulations
you just made sure that a terrible
captain will be sticking around here
indefinitely
come on santiago we're just trying to
make the best of it
you okay never yes 40 000 steps
[Music]
what is that it's a statue of her
texting on our phone
guys look there's a note
hello nine-nine i just wanted to thank
you guys i was so nervous to move on
and i even started to doubt myself which
is crazy
and your kind words really helped me
especially yours terry
did he fall terry did you fall for it
anyway terry that's your gina moment
seriously i've known her for seven years
jk again
i'm really gonna miss you sarge i signed
you up for an international yogurt of
the month club austria is in the fridge
right now
terry's never had austrian yogurt before
terry had the best moment of all
i see you filming linetty what's in the
yogurt normal stuff
nothing you'd use to make a sidewalk
with i know it's crowded in there
and they're not very considerate guests
and they took my mouse
and then they took my keyboard and then
they took the whole computer
and when i had nothing else to give they
came for my yogurt
no not just any yogurt full fat greek
with a touch of honey
that's a once a week treat
what the hell are you guys doing out
here finally eating breakfast
we snuck the microwave out here so that
we could cook our burritos like real
policemen now they have to use the
toaster oven
enjoy your 16-minute cook times idiots
guys this is amazing back off it's our
microwave
ours nobody wants your microwave
captain why are you giggling i put a gps
tracker
inside of terry sarge kevin purchased
one too many
full fat french yogurts you want it
absolutely
enjoy jeffords enjoy devious
i know but i also put a tracker in
terry's yogurt same here no reason
just cause you're a great sergeant now
suck it down
yeah no problem take it swallow the girt
do you guys think all that radiation is
bad for him i'm sure he'll be fine
he's lived a long life already yeah
jake tell us everything did you call
amy's dad first i actually did
mr santiago i'm calling to inform you
that i plan to ask your daughter to
marry me
but since it's 2017 i am not asking for
your permission as she is not your
property nor would she be mine if she
chooses to say yes
she's a strong independent woman and she
don't need no man that being said i
truly hope she says yes but it's her
decision so just back off
oh that was perfect what did he say i
have no idea i left a voicemail i'm
terrified of him
not to talk out of turn but i think i
get credit for giving jake the idea to
propose
how's that remember a day in the kitchen
so what i'm saying is
vanilla yogurt is good but pair it with
a blueberry yogurt
and both of them taste even better get
it
yes i did not get it but speaking of
yogurt you've eaten six gps devices this
week you should definitely see a doc
what
you